Iceman Ace fighter pilot volleyball
Enthusiast and the real hero of the Top
Gun franchise it might not be as crazy
as it sounds
Top Gun was penned by the screenwriting
team of Jack Epps Jr and Jim cash who in
the 1980s were two of the hottest
writers in the business as they worked
on the Top Gun script they realized on
one level that it's actually more of a
sports film than a war movie which
opened up many new possibilities for
their story as EPS explained from my
point of view as a writer Top Gun is a
sports movie and the sport is ACM aerial
combat maneuvering much alike in the
World of Sports Top Gun features a loss
of young talents who are eager to prove
themselves so that ends the writers set
a number of important scenes in locker
rooms mostly because this is a place
where the characters can speak to each
other in a manner that might not be
possible when they're in uniform
it's not clear whether the characters in
Top Gun are based on real people or not
but some people believe that Iceman was
indeed based on a real-life fighter
pilot according to the military
publication Stars and Stripes ice was
based on a fighter pilot named Dennis
Tech who went by the same cool sign Tech
played guitar in a cold band called
radio Birdman and studied medicine in
Australia once he got back to the United
States in 1981 he joins the Navy and
became a flight surgeon according to
Tech himself the makers of Top Gun spent
time with the Squadron doing research
for the film in fact one of Tech's old
military buddies said the characters
seemed so similar he was even more
intense than the movie Iceman yet Jack
Epps Jr who co-wrote the film said the
character wasn't based on any real-life
military man insisting that basing their
characters on real people might have
brought up and wanted legal problems for
the film's crew in the movie sleep with
me Quentin Tarantino delivered a riff on
Top Gun claiming that it's actually a
gay movie in Disguise so since their
numerous series have popped up online
about the apparent homoerotic subtext of
Top Gun but David Paul Kirkpatrick a
former executive at Paramount says this
wasn't intentional he wrote on Facebook
much has been made of the homoerotic
nature of Top Gun particularly the
volleyball sequence but it wasn't
intentional the guys in the movie were
young and in good shape for their
respective parts and Tony Scott shot the
scene quickly at Magic hour which gave
it that Golden Glow Kirkpatrick
continued a volleyball sequence stayed
in the movie only because the women
adored the scene in previous it's
because the sequence exhibited non-toxic
masculinity at its finest non-aggressive
Greek gods playing ball slathered in
suntan lotion and wearing Ray-Bans in
later years however the film attracted a
significant gay following and it brought
many in search of their sexuality at a
young age as Robert W fiesler explained
in slate Iceman and Maverick jetted
life-saving homoeroticism Pastor
generation of conservative parents no
adults naughty even a minister would bat
an eyelash when I said knowingly to
their sons kids I hope to a closeted gay
too Top Gun is my favorite film it
actually took some convincing to get Val
Kilmer to commit to top gun as kyoma
recalled he and Crews had the same agent
so he knew about the project but he
wasn't convinced I just really wasn't
interested in it and they were like very
Tony's guard very much
but uh I turned it down as Kilmer
remembered director Tony Scott then ran
after Kilmer got in front of the
elevator so he couldn't leave and told
him he's gotta do it man
it's gonna be great and he described uh
you know with this enthusiasm and relish
how it was going to be seen kyoma was
finally won over by his enthusiasm
although a number of contractual
obligations to paramounts helped things
along
in a movie full of cocky young guys out
to prove themselves it would only be
natural there would be some tension off
screen as well whether there was indeed
any true rivalry between Tom Cruise and
Val Kilmer is unclear but they certainly
kept their distance often when actors
play rivals in a film they'll stay away
from each other while the movie is
shooting on Top Gun Kilmer stayed close
with his on-screen buddies Hollywood and
Wolfman while Maverick and Goose stayed
tight Cruz also stayed out of any of the
off-screen partying that Kilmer and his
Top Gun buddies got involved in Kilmer
later said I would purposefully play up
the Rivalry between Tom's character and
mine off screen as well it was fun to
play up the conflict between our
characters but in reality I've always
thought of Tom as a friend and we've
always supported each other and that all
was well on the top gun set though in a
documentary on the making of the movie
kioma said he believed Cruz might have
sabotaged the footage from the
volleyball game Tony Scott apparently
told Kilmer the Shots featuring him had
been cooked meaning they were over or
underdeveloped and unusable for the film
in order to deliver their best
performances many actors crafted
backstories for the characters they play
the audience may never know about this
but it's nevertheless important for
actors to have something to draw on when
they perform when Kilmer agreed to play
Iceman he created a backstory for the
character that gave him some added depth
as the actor said in his documentary Val
on the page there was very little to the
character Iceman so I attempted to make
him real I manifested a backstory for
him where he had a father who ignored
him and as a result was driven by the
need to be perfect in every way this
obsession with Perfections is what made
him so arrogant this backstory brings so
much more to Top Gun because Maverick
struggles with similar issues as he
desperately seeks to live up to his late
father's Legend as a pilot
Top Gun is a story that inspired
audiences around the world it was a
number one movie of 1986 making 176
million dollars at the domestic box
office since starring in the film Kilmer
is being recognized as Iceman for over
three decades by pilots and the film
famously increased military enlistment
reportedly the U.S Navy had more
applications than had in years after the
success of Top Gun and there have been
reports that the film made Naval
Recruiting increased by 500 though this
figure may have been exaggerated at the
same time as one Navy vet said I saw the
movie I thought it looked like the most
exciting job in the world and it is in
recent years the Navy has been having
problems enlisting new recruits it
remains to be seen where the top gun
Maverick would turn this around for the
service
Tom Cruise was clearly the star of Top
Gun and he starred in the film right as
he was becoming one of the hottest
actors in Hollywood in recent years
however some fans have come to realize
how important Iceman is to the story
with many even believing that he is the
real hero of the movie in one critique
of collider for example the writer noted
ice man is just as essential to the
success of the final mission when
Maverick gets all his Acclaim in the end
Maverick gets all the glory but Maverick
is more traditionally heroic both as a
pilot and as a character as many other
fans point out Maverick himself is
reckless and dangerous but Iceman is
call under pressure and far more
together than the young protagonist who
strives to prove he's a real Hotshot and
whether you think he's a hero or not
there's no question Iceman is a crucial
component in the Top Gun storyline after
all without him Maverick's character Arc
and growth wouldn't be anywhere near as
dramatic or compelling
pilot you or me
[Music]
nice moment it's not ruining although
some Crews there's a star of Top Gun
Maverick the fact that Iceman returned
for a brief but memorable segment shows
there is still plenty of Goodwill for
the character in fact as producer Jerry
Bruckheimer explained Tom said he wasn't
going to make the movie without him Cruz
confirmed this too as he recalls I
really rallied hard for him to make the
movie the kind of talent that He has and
you see that scene it's very special
Cruz apparently told brookheimer that
Kilmer simply had to come back for the
second Top Gun movie it was a wonderful
reunion for brockheimer too who had
worked with Kilmer on the original Top
Gun
well Val kilma was initially skittish
about taking on the role of Iceman in
the original Top Gun he was reportedly
delighted that his character is still
beloved by fans and filmmakers that's
exactly why he signed on to one of the
biggest box office hits of all time with
top gun Maverick in fact as Jerry
Bruckheimer explained we called Val and
told him we wanted to meet him to be in
the picture and he was thrilled and as
kilma's son jack told People magazine
they honored a legacy of Iceman and he
was so stoked by It when Jack and his
sister Mercedes went down to the San
Diego Naval Base where Maverick was
shooting real life Navy Pilots came up
to them and told them that Top Gun had
inspired them to join the armed forces
Jack said it was one of the proudest
moments of being American that you could
think of really Against All Odds
especially with Kilmer's speaking voice
being so badly damaged kilma's scene
with Cruz and Maverick makes her one of
the movie's most powerful moments Kilmer
later said that when Iceman and Maverick
hug in their scene together it was
straight from the heart I love Tom
had a hand in developing Iceman's story
in the sequel iceman has moved up to
Amaral and his life is coming to an end
due to a devastating illness it was
actually Kilmer's idea to have Iceman be
a mentor to Maverick and he discussed
his ideas for the role with Cruz
Maverick director Joseph kazinski and
Jerry Bruckheimer at first Kilmer types
out his dialogue to Cruz then he finally
speaks telling him
the Navy
needs Maverick watching the finished
segments of Maverick and Iceman together
kilma record I was very moved the first
time I saw it almost 40 years is a long
time for a reunion
the door was always open for Iceman to
return in the second Top Gun film the
problem was that Val Kilmer has survived
a diagnosis of throat cancer and now has
trouble speaking as a result birds with
the help of today's technology kilma was
able to return to Top Gun kioma worked
with a company called sonantec who
created an AI voice that was put
together from hours of footage of Kilmer
speaking in movies these recordings were
then run into algorithms to create a new
voice for the actor as an executive at
sunantic said in the end we generated
more than 40 different voice models and
selected the best highest quality most
expressive one in the future other
actors will be able to recreate their
voices like this as well Kilmer said in
a statement that he was grateful that
the company could restore his voice and
that the chance to narrate my story in a
voice that feels authentic and familiar
is an incredibly special gift
[Music]